yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Rainmaker I am Rainmaker we have
to really adjust the windows here they
kind of screwed up just a second down
yep the national master Olaf zap that is
ok so let's see we get Kings in your
night I don't really have a clear memory
what I have played against him in
earlier games going to go for the h3
Bishop g5 line the line that I sometimes
play against the Kings engine I don't
have a very clear repertoire there
against assaulting a play a couple of
lines Queen B 6 uh-huh
okay so I understand so if i go to see
tool that's going to be a little bit
unfortunate as be 2x and i don't want to
give up the bishop of some and should be
one is a little bit clumsy queen a six
maybe a threatening 93 that looks a bit
strange okay here i have fun the option
of taking only have six actually and
then take with the knight on d5 this is
normally not a good idea but my position
is a little bit a little bit off i
wonder if i should take this option yeah
i think i'm doing it it's a little bit
strange to be honest it's not what you
usually want to do but check if I said I
wasn't so happy with my bishop jaan be
one so the regular positions looked a
little bit a little bit weird as well I
don't have a very good bishop here of
course so yeah
96 is the thing okay i have to push this
away any hour
celebra with the space advantage but
it's not fantastic or anything like the
position seems quite reasonable it that
that's often the kind of situation that
you get from amarok see bind in out of
the accelerated dragon all the English
where um black has been able to exchange
two pairs of minor pieces set should
normally give him quite a decent game
yeah this is an interesting interesting
move and I thought about it and I wasn't
quite sure how how good this is yeah
it's a bit awkward I cannot easily move
the night I would like to play a to c 3
and not steak but I maybe have to check
one thing that I wonder is actually if I
play like this to being able to play
Bishop f3 I don't want to play contrary
yeah this is the thing that feels
extremely ugly but he also has
weaknesses on the B porn and the d6 pawn
and therefore is also kind of the
potential target it looks a little bit
strange what I did here but I don't
think it's so bad oh my god is the kind
of move that kind of that goo okay yeah
I take it f3 is absolutely terrible so
so much for my idea if you can just take
age three I might still have enough play
against his weaknesses but it renders my
idea pretty much yeah not good no touch
and leave this one
[Music]
the h-bond shouldn't be all that
relevant and landing oh come on now
you're playing miracle chess or what d 5
okay imma take it takes on g2 takes m3k
okay so what's happening here it should
be for what should be seven I don't get
it what's going on
should what I don't understand anything
yet is does he have something really
good now that I don't see and we cannot
attack my queen it should be 725 is that
a problem I don't think so don't see
something really really great should you
for him yeah he I'm taking of course he
can perpetual me now but it's not much
not much to do about it can take a three
and then check me on GNH phone check it
does not have an easy way to get down to
get a rook involved at least I don't see
it there's no 6-ranked this would be
also us over if there was a g6 gonna be
on g7 yeah this is 45
this one
the Rope g1 check check and I'm escaping
to h1
did I will look something feel a little
bit irritated here check I can take that
30 cause I'm such a [ __ ] can take care
three didn't see that didn't see that at
all that's awful it's really really
awful time morning anyway to to post
some problems here I know it's probably
too bad
quindi one is made for a buddy game
check pretty awful
I don't think I'm going over there often
plays d5 rather the opposite don't think
that this can be any good just didn't
see a 38 you can just play okay one
check there are offered quite resigned
radicals that was pretty awful don't
think that this should work at all it
does work what really this is a winning
position from black let's not too much I
leave I with Queen age five that wins
okay and then I understand of course
yeah if it takes a three check can this
cannot be that great I don't believe it
no it isn't it isn't hmm yeah maybe it
is a problem yeah okay the whole issue
was that he could take on a three of
course which well it should be prevented
the debit it was a really good move yeah
d 5 is a shocker there but apparently
very strong apparently very strong the
engine already am it doesn't find a rule
for me to claim check yeah Queen h5 then
why not stronger yeah this is this is
quite clearly losing check check which
are here probably you need a little bit
more depth the engine to talk to
reliably say how this is to be evaluated
it has a slight edge for black which is
kind of hard to interpret what that
means now this is not working change in
T can see that i have three was hanging
and
is a complete loss yeah I don't know
usually this trans generation doesn't
net much wyd NT it was a probably
roughly equal yeah I should probably do
something else in I mean there are a
couple of options I don't need to play
what I did but I thought it was
interesting the move be five by the end
you like kind of dislike I don't know
that looks a little bit all does it look
very nice my bishop is pretty bad i have
the space but yeah this is just
basically failing due to this is this
tactic we should h3 my idea was that if
you forget about bishop h3 for a moment
just to play Bishop f3 and and then put
pressure on the pawns here i would be in
very good shape i think or like yeah
maybe a very good shape but at least a
bit better but there is Bishop age 3 so
this is just the reputation of my whole
idea Jim and here you're just an in
terrible shape you can play Quincy three
but essentially it's a pawn down and
black as the attack so this is pretty
bad yeah probably I shouldn't do this
this Bishop of six thing it's so and
this is the normal way to play and I
probably should have done that I mean it
doesn't look particularly I deal with
the bishop stuck on be one but you can
you can fix that in the next couple of
moves and what what's the cell is is a
fairly normal Kings inion ok guys thanks
for watching